all right thanks everybody for coming my
name is rafael bull so I'm probably the
most foreign object in this room I work
on on quantum gravity and cosmology over
in the physics department and I want to
welcome you to this mini workshop on
major space-time and tensor networks let
me just say one or two words about the
history of this workshop there's sort of
a large scale and a small scale reason
for it the large scale reason is that
certainly from my perspective I perceive
that that techniques in condensed matter
and quantum information have well be an
understatement to say that they've
played an increasing role in recent
years in my field I would say they've
been central to revolutionising my field
and it seems clear now that those of us
who are interested in understanding how
space-time works huh quantum gravity
works are going to need to learn the
techniques that you guys have developed
in in these other fields and pencil
networks are one from an example notions
from quantum information such as the
property of entanglement entropy or
another and you know if we knew exactly
what we need we wouldn't have needed
this workshop the idea is to get to you
teach each other some of these
techniques that we vaguely feel are
relevant and to teach each other the
problems that we care about a lot of you
might have the solution to something
that you don't even know is a problem
and that was that was one of the goals
on a smaller scale you're all
participating in an arranging marriage
it's not monogamous unlike entanglement
entropy but I hope it works out anyway
so I'm hoping that the groups that are
here represented by omission and Joel
and myself will win in the future find
ways to interact more with each other
and we're really also just trying to
teach each other our respective fields
and and I think Berkeley's is in
very good position to take advantage of
the expertise that's here so thank you
all for coming and helping us with that
and and I've encouraged to learning a
lot today and the talks again today are
I really aimed not necessarily sort of
primarily as presenting research results
and cutting-edge stuff but but it
I think pedagogical there's a lot of
time for discussion and no question is
too naive so I'd like to invite Patrick
to start he's one of the people really
pioneered breaking through the barriers
between these fields and he will talk
about space-time and repeating a lot of
information all right I like that you
had to actually read my title even
though you're the one who assigned the
title so I'm going to try to be
pedagogical the intention is to try to
illustrate some of the connections
between space-time entropy and quantum
information I am going to present some
some work with the Bartek check Brian
Swingle both of whom are here at new
melash Carrie but in the context of
trying to present a larger set of
questions and then the talk is going to
trail off towards the end and just be a
list of questions hopefully prompting
discussion with the rest of you so just
to set the context for the computer
scientists one of the major questions
that we're interested in here is the
relationship between entanglement in the
structure of space-time and there's a
there's a setting in which let's call it
a toy a toy example in which we can
actually examine some of those questions
and that's called the anti de sitter
space conformal field theory
correspondents so this is a a theory of
quantum gravity in the in a particular
setting so it's a theory of quantum
gravity so we can picture is sort of a
universe in a bottle um so say d + 2
dimensional theory there's a
gravitational theory but asymptotical e
this space is anti-de sitter space which
means as i'm todd eclis it's the
maximally symmetric negatively curved
spacetime and you can put stuff in the
model in the
you know deep inside if you want and see
what happens now what's interesting in
this context or this for this theory of
quantum gravity is that it is thought
and there's great deal evidence to
supporting this conjecture that the
theory of quantum gravity is precisely
equivalent to a standard quantum field
theory so say just a theory of qubits
living on the boundary of this
space-time so as I said this is a
space-time that's kind of in a bottle
someone who's inside can send a a signal
shine a light towards the boundary we'll
get to the signal get to the boundary
and come back in finite time well you
can place this quantum field theory
living on the boundary again a theory of
qubits the boundaries has one fewer
spatial dimensions and all questions
that you'd want to ask about quantum
gravity and principle can be asked in
the in the in the boundary Theory the
boundary doesn't have gravity so it
eliminates a lot of the complications of
thinking about a gravitational theory or
maybe oh it's just a standard quantum
theory so this is this is a in
particular a context in which we see
something kind of miraculous occurring
which is the emergence of one direction
of space right the radial direction of
space isn't present in the boundary
theory but it's somehow it's present in
the bulk theory and so the analogy that
is often given in this context is that
is Plato's cave you know to think back
to this story that Plato gave someone
lives in a cave all he sees is the
projections on the wall of the cave of
something that's happening outside and
if you try to you can imagine if you
were in this situation he tried to
construct a theory of the shadows this
would be a very nonsensical theory that
the shadows themselves don't have enough
information to predict their own future
behavior but in this context really
quite miraculously the the shadows being
of course the the play of what's
happening on the boundary there's enough
information there to predict the future
behavior and on top of that not only is
there enough information but those
shadows behave according to the rules of
some local physics right now which is
really quite a miracle yeah that's
something a miracle so again just
zooming in we're going to be speaking
mostly about space rather than
space-time so the spatial slice of
anti-de sitter is hyperbolic space and
so
the metric is you know this rendition
the fish counting metric the distance
between a and B is the smallest number
of fish you have to pass through to get
from A to B it's negatively curved so
the you know the sum of the angle
interior angles of a triangle is less
than 180 degrees much of what I'm going
to say I'm going to sort of be focusing
on the 2-dimensional case our
two-dimensional space some of it
generalizes some of it does not and
that's one of the questions that we're
interested is the extent to which some
of these ideas generalize
now as I said you can put stuff inside
your space-time so for example you could
drop a black hole deep inside ATS and
ask what happens now that's going to
distort the geometry and so your
geodesics are no longer going to be just
the the curves that I've drawn here they
might look something more like this and
if you want you can write down the
metric but we're not going to focus on
that for the moment now this connection
there's this idea that there's a
connection between entanglement and the
structure of space so where did that
idea come from
and that actually I'd say first
originated by thinking about a
particular example the two-sided a D s
black hole and this and this is a what's
called a Penrose diagram and it's a way
of thinking about the causal structure
of a given space-time and so in this
diagram it's it it's drawn such such
that light rays propagate at 45 degrees
like I've drawn here and so if I think
about being at this point in the space
time time is say in the vertical
direction and I shine a light ray out
that way it's going to hit the boundary
which is this vertical line and each
point in the diagram has a say a
2-dimensional sphere attached to it and
so this vertical line here represents
the boundary there's a conformal field
theory living on that boundary on the
other hand I can also shine Ray's in
this way and the horizontal direction I
should say is the radial direction in
this space-time and ya move to this
region and if I'm in this region of the
space-time as you can see any light rays
that I shoot out eventually are going to
hit this singularity and so this is
being this is the interior of the black
hole this wedge up top and this piece
outside the wedge yeah the sideways
triangle is the
the exterior the black hole but if you
look at the picture there is another
region on the left which looks very much
like the region on the right and so this
black hole actually has two exterior
regions and so each exterior region
looks like some space time there's a
black hole in it but if you were to jump
into the black hole that interior is
shared between the two space times and
that's how they're they're linked
together and so you can think of it as
the interior of the black hole forming
an entre versatile wormhole between
these two exterior regions and you know
just to draw the picture if I think
about this spatial slice here it's a-you
know it has a shape that looks somewhat
like this sort of abstractly now there's
as we said before there's a conformal
field theory associated with each
boundary in the space-time and so
there's a quantum state living on that
conformal field theory and the in this
particular case because we have two
boundaries there are two conformal field
theories and we can ask what is the
quantum state associated with this
particular geometry and the quantum
state associate with this particular
geometry has a very interesting form
it's an entangled state between left and
right and it's entangled in a very
particular way there's actually a
Hamiltonian associated with the system
it's the sum of two independent parts
one for the left one for the right
there's no interaction between them and
so we just have a state which is this is
the the schmitt basis and it looks like
the purification of a thermal state all
right so if we were to trace over left
and think about the state on the right
this would be a thermal density operator
and so the thermal density operator in
the conformal field theory corresponds
to a black hole geometry but the fact
that the two exteriors are linked
through the wormhole corresponds in this
their manifests itself in this context
in the state being an entangled state
between the conformal two conformal
field theories and so this generated the
idea which was I guess you have
elaborated by several people over time
that the entanglement between the
conforte two conformal field theories
generates or links them together through
this that through this this link of
space this wormhole
now I guess one should also say that one
can construct geometries one-sided black
hole geometries in which the there is no
wormhole and then confirm that the the
lack of entanglement corresponds to the
lack of some of some kind of bridge
connecting them so this idea I should
say has been with initially observed in
this example and yes when the what like
these boundaries right here so each
boundary like in this external picture
let's go back this picture here each of
them at each point in time is one of
these these spheres right maybe the
picture going back a bit further each of
them each of the space times looks like
this but there's a black hole in it so
you sort of have two bottles like this
but the inside the black hole they're
linked together is the way to think
about it that makes sense
that's tango exist could exist or
actually describes the like this the
status of this state here um so I'm I'm
not an expert on how one does these
calculations but I think there's a great
deal of confidence and the people in the
room who know much more about how one
does the calculations that that in the
80s CFD correspondents there's a good
justification for this being the correct
quantum state that describes this
particular geometry yes exactly
yeah okay so the question right and this
is not a question will be resolved today
but a question for discussion then is
how far can you generalize this example
does space actually emerge from
entanglement itself of some amorphous
non geometrically organized degrees of
freedom and some strong evidence in that
direction was first well some further
evidence in that direction was found by
thinking about entanglement in conformal
field theories that have these gravity
duals
and that was actually well we'll get
there but to work by were you and Takeo
Nagi and shouldn't a review is in the
audience somewhere I think so the
situation there is that you have a
conformal field theory again so just
think of it as a bunch of qubits and in
this case they organized in a ring and
you want to calculate the entanglement
entropy so there's a reduced density
operator for some region on the ring the
formulas minus trace of Rho log row for
the density operator and so the
entanglement entropy if the you have a
pure states of the of the ring is of
course just the amount of entanglement
between a and a complement and the
remarkable formula proposed by route Rio
and takahagi is that if you want to
evaluate this entanglement entropy which
a priori involves find me the density
operator diagonalizing the density
operator you're calculating this
function there's a very simple beautiful
geometrical way to do it in the in the
holographic dual and what you do is you
calculate the error
of some minimal surface associated with
a and the surface that you look at in
this simple example you think about
surfaces that begin and end on the
endpoints of the interval of the
interval a and have minimal length in
the bulk geometry now if you remember
the fish counting metric there are many
more fish out near the boundary than
there are in the middle and so this
minimalist this this geodesic is going
to not hug the boundary it's going to
penetrate into the bulk and so that's
going to that's that's and that's
actually how you calculate the the
entanglement entropy now the technical
definition is that you think about
surfaces in the Buttler in the bulk that
are homologous to this boundary region a
so that they are the common boundary of
some some region in the bulk and that's
important sometimes rather than thing
rather than its being deformed or rather
than deforming a into the bulk so this
formula generalizes the
well-known and long-standing area
beautiful formula for black hole entropy
that in that context if you remember the
black hole corresponding to a thermal
state of the boundary theory and so if
we wanted to find the entropy of the
black hole we could ask well what is the
entropy of the whole boundary and in
this case the the rule is going to allow
this this surface to contract into the
bulk and the minimal surface is going to
wrap around the the horizon of the black
hole and calculate the horizon the area
of the horizon um so this was originally
proposed based on numerical agreement
that they that were you and takia Nagi
had some particular examples where they
could calculate the left side and the
right side and see that they agreed and
then additional evidence was found at
this point I think there's a pretty good
explanation and confidence that the
formula is correct to leading order in
these theories so that leaves the for an
information theorist like myself that
leaves the question of how we would
actually interpret this boundary entropy
what do what does it really mean in
terms of the bulk theory can we actually
learn something try
how far can we push it in term in order
to get a better sense of the
relationship between entanglement
structure in the boundary theory and
geometry in the bulk because I guess I
should I should emphasize that what's
remarkable about the formula is it
translates directly quantitatively
entanglement right in the boundary
theory in the form of entanglement
entropy into a purely geometrical
quantity in the bulk theory right
relating these two things together and
if our goal is to understand whether we
space time or space emerges from
entanglement this seems like a great
starting point so the information
theoretic interpretation of entropy is
the minimum compression rate or even a
most let's say the minimum compression
rate but that the minimal number of
qubits required to encode the quantum
information associated with that region
so if our Alice was external to this
ring right you can imagine that this
ring now is just a ring of some exotic
material that Alice has in her own
laboratory and then she has she's going
to look at the a part and try to
compress that down to the minimal number
of qubits while maintaining all of the
correlations with a complement the
minimal number of qubits required is the
entropy under some assumptions now
there's a sort of interesting
coincidence happening here right which
is that entropy is the minimum overall
compression procedures of the cost but
in the Rio tockia nagi formula the the
entropy is the minimum over all curves
of the length of the curve so wouldn't
it be great and interesting and you know
a further development of this
relationship between geometry and
entanglement if there was a sense in
which every curve correspondent to some
way to compress the quantum information
subject to some restrictions determined
by the geometry of the curve and that
turns out to be true yeah in a certain
sense so to make that true we have to
alter a little bit our notion of what we
mean by compressing at least at least
provisionally just by virtue of the fact
that yeah this is all we can prove at
this point or understand
and so if Alice wanted to compress or
qubits to send them to Bob another thing
she could do is she could first compress
them
and then teleport them to Bob right and
the number of Bell pairs required to
teleport would be the number of qubits
she'd originally compressed to and so
it's sort of an equivalent way of saying
the same thing is that the minimal
number of Bell pairs required to
teleport the a region from Alice to Bob
is given by the entropy and this is the
statement it's the equivalent in this
context but not necessarily equivalent
in general that we're going to we're
going to elaborate on so what is the the
sort of the the rough architecture of
the bulk there's sort of an idea that's
you know developed over time and well
we're going to try to understand this
geodesic sort of in little incremental
bits and the idea is that the pieces
near the boundary are going to
correspond to small scale correlations
in the boundary theory oh yeah in the
physics jargon ultraviolet correlations
and so here we have perhaps two sources
of information that are correlated with
in some small community of interest to
some small community and near the center
you have correlations on a larger scale
right so there might sort of information
that might be of interest broadly to a
much larger community and the the type
of compression procedure that is going
to be relevant is a streaming
compression procedure so I just like to
give you an analogy in a very concrete
context in which many of us have
encountered it before and so this is
Netflix right if you use your laptop you
want to watch a movie if Netflix wanted
to minimize the number of bits that they
were going to send you in total then
what they would do is they'd compress
the whole movie at once on their side
and they send it to you right and if
they do that that would exploit both
what we think of as the UV correlation
right the the correlations that are
local in time in the movie so here's a
some stills from interstellar I guess
with you have exhibited ultraviolet
correlation this is a movie by the way
in which solving the problems of quantum
gravity turn out to ya solve or prevent
humanity from total destruction and so
yeah it's really great for the ego of
somebody who's interested in quantum
gravity
but this
this compression of the whole movie at
once will also be able to make maximum
and complete use of the infrared
correlations right the correlations that
are that are over long time intervals in
the movie and so for example the Star
Matthew McConaughey his face yeah is the
same face you know in at each point in
the movie modulo you know being happy or
scared and so that type of correlation
could be used in this context now that's
not what Netflix actually does because
when you hit play on a movie they want
to be able to display the movie to you
in real time right away and as a result
they have to sacrifice on the infrared
correlations right they can only make
use of short time correlations and not
long time correlations and that's sort
of the nature of a streaming compression
protocol the lara the longer a window
you have access to or the larger window
the better you can compress and if you
only have access to to the ultraviolet
information then you're going to have to
pay an additional cost so what does that
have to do with holography well Vijay
Bala Subramanian Bartek and
collaborators back in 2013 found a way
or observed that you could map a general
curve in the bulk to a sequence of
boundary intervals in the following
fashion so here my boundary is supposed
to be this horizontal line here so
that's a that's a spatial part of the
boundary and then I have a curve this
piece that penetrates into the bulk and
at each point on that bulk curve I can
construct the tangent geodesic and the
geodesics if you remember sort of well
in this case they're actually semi
circles and so they will intersect the
boundary at two points and so each tenth
tangent each for each point on the
boundary theory we have a tangent
geodesic will intersect the boundary at
two points and so that defines an
interval in the boundary and so the
curve can be translated into a sequence
of intervals on the boundary like I've
drawn here so here's the sequence of
intervals and we could use that sequence
of intervals to define or to to
constrain a streaming compression
protocol that we could have Alice who's
trying to send the contents of the
interval the quant
information of the boundary theory to
Bob but she's going to have to do it in
a sequence of steps one for each
interval and at each one of those steps
she only has access to the part of the
boundary defined by the interval so I've
drawn her large here but she would start
off only having access to this very
small interval and she could do whatever
she wants and we're gonna allow her to
use that bell pairs with Bob right so
it's like teleportation will count the
number of bell pairs and Bob is
similarly constrained he's gonna have a
sort of replica system of Alice's and
he's allowed to act on his set of qubits
that are localized in space in the same
way that Alice's are at each step and so
Alice will sort of move through the
boundary interval I didn't know how to
make the animation to show the size of
our interval changing as a function of
time but you know she starts off only
having access to the very small bit it
grows and grows and grows and scale at
some point she has to start moving to
the right and the interval eventually
shrinks down to nothing again and so we
could ask in this context if Alice is
trying to communicate her state to Bob
using the fewest number of Bell pairs
possible how many Bell pairs are
possibly Oh are required and what you
can show is that the length of this
curve is the minimal entanglement the
minimal number of Bell pairs required
for Alice to transfer the subtended
portion of the boundary state to Bob
using a streaming teleportation protocol
with curve dependent locality and scale
constraints and so the geometry of the
bulk is translated into a sort of
information theoretic structure in the
boundary and constraints on the way that
Alice can access the boundary sort of
input you know create a sort of well
reflect the metrics about the structure
of the bulk um now there are two parts
to to proving this kind of result and I
think I'll tell you something about how
why it's true or the why Alice can
actually do this but one has to both
show that it's possible for Alice to do
this and one has to show that Alice that
there's there's no way to do it with
fewer qubits right that if you really
want to have an interpretation
as the minimal cost you have to not only
show that there's a way to achieve that
cost you have to show there's no way to
do better I'm not going to tell you much
at all about how why it's the Y's that's
possible but I just want to emphasize
that that is also something that's known
and just to illustrate right so here we
have a a curve which stays close to the
boundary there and as a result the the
intervals defined by the curve are all
very short right and so this is a
streaming compression protocol in which
you only have access to the ultraviolet
information and so the length of the
curve is large and if you remember the
number of fish out near the boundary is
very high so a curve that stays near the
boundary has a has a high cost
conversely if you allow the curve to
penetrate into the bulk you have access
to more of the infrared information you
can let it go further and further and
further into the bulk and at some point
you find the length of the minimal curve
so that's the cost of a compression
protocol with no constraints at all so
why is this true I'm just going to end
in the pedagogical spirit I'll tell you
about how how Bartek it all made sense
of the the length of an arbitrary curve
yep
let's say it's a pure state of the full
ring and she's trying to send a portion
so it could also be that it's a mixed
state of the ring purified by some other
system so it's that the all of the
correlations of a with the rest of the
world have to be preserved well it's the
a in a compliment right like it's the
usual definition if you want to talk
about quantum compression right so
there's a density operator on a and this
procedure should work for all possible
purifications of a yeah so so for this
to be true the so I guess there's an
important constraint which I didn't I
didn't get her I didn't get into which
is that entropies are generally not the
answers to that like if I ask the
question what is the minimal number of
qubits required to compress some state
the the von Neumann entropy is usually
not the answer right that it's usually
just abstractly it's the log of the
dimension of the portion of Hilbert
space that you need and only when some
law of large numbers comes into effect
as the von Neumann entropy come yes
become the right answer
so in this context so this result works
we've proven it only in for a boundary
that has one spatial dimension and you
have to have a large it's in the limit
that the central charges the CFT goes to
infinity because what you really need
for it to work is that at every
discretized step of the procedure the
entropy has to be large and in the
conforming like in conformal field
theories in at least in one plus one
dimension like this you can prove that
the von Neumann entropy and this
compression cost are essentially the
same or the the corrections go as the
square root of the entropy and so to get
the leading order correction you the
entropy to be able to be large
the more general cases this also gives
you a bomb yes so more generally what
you can I mean I'll tell you a little
bit about why it's true but you can
replace these n trapeze by their
one-shot versions and then you can prove
a result but then there's going to be a
gap and optimally of what you can prove
is optimal or sort of what you can prove
is required will not match what you can
prove is achievable there'll be some
separation between them sorry yes
exactly yep well that really is the
content of the of the result that the I
mean it's I think maybe my picture here
is a little bit misleading that the the
length of the blue window is actually
varying as Alice moves from left to
right that the the length of the window
is actually given by the lengths of
these intervals that I've drawn below
and so if the intervals become law
become long then the compression
protocol can be more effective and it's
and the relationship is precisely that
the cost of the compression protocol for
a given collection of window sizes is
the length of the curve
okay so and this that's that's
illustrated here right so if you have a
curve where the window sizes are small
then it's then the length of the curve
is long whereas if you allow yourself
longer intervals the length of the curve
becomes smaller till it's at its minimal
size so why is this true
now so this this starts from a story as
I said a Bartek and collaborators back
in 2013 the Rio Takia nagi formula
allows you to make sense of the length
of a geodesic but doesn't tell you
anything about the length of an
arbitrary curve and so they came up with
a way of a formula for the length of an
arbitrary curve so here's a curve it
doesn't actually start and end on the
boundary but in the bulk my curve gamma
and just to illustrate I've taken this
picture from Rob Myers how would you go
about expressing it in terms of boundary
quantities so what you could do is you
could say well let's draw tangent
geodesics to that curve like we were
talking about before so the tangent
geodesics are these blue lines that
become red and then blue again and as
you can see if you if you if you draw a
bunch of these things then they're kind
of outer envelope is going to
approximate the length of the curve and
so you could say all right well let's
try to add up the lengths of these of
those geodesics that we've drawn and if
we do that well we get this outer
envelope but we also get these blue
parts that we don't like all right so
you have to try to correct for the blue
parts and so for each each of the blue
red geodesics that's associated with an
interval in the boundary my I 1 then I 2
then I 3 and you could at least try to
correct by saying well I want to
subtract off these legs these blue legs
and I could think about the geodesic
that starts at one of the light at the
Diego leg of one interval and ends at
the leg of the other right so that's
corresponding to the the interval which
is the overlap of two consecutive
intervals and it doesn't look like it's
a great approximation in this picture
but you should again remember that most
of the fish are out at the boundary
right and so just subtracting off the
greens is going to do a pretty good job
of approximating the length of the of
the curve gamma and as you take the
limit where the shift between the
intervals becomes infinitesimal the
actually becomes an exact formula and so
I'm just writing this schematically as
the infinite sum of the the entropy
associated with the Cape interval this
one here - the entropy associated with
the intersection of the cave and the K -
K - first cave - one right here so
that's the green piece and this is the
formula that for the length of a curve a
general curve and they call this the
differential entropy so differential
because as you can see this is really an
integral of some kind of derivative but
we'll just write it in this finite
language so does this mean anything in
information theory so we are behind
should we check it yeah I can I can just
I think that's that sets the stage I
guess we started a little bit late but I
don't I don't care how far I go so so
let me just take a quick look I'll just
say one thing about why it's true and
because and then we'll we get to the
discussion so so how do we connect
Bartek and alt observation to the
protocol that I was just describing and
so if we have some physical space so now
this is a two dimensional physical space
with two sub regions a and B then we can
think about the various entropic
quantities associated to a and B so
there's a an entropy of a which we've
talked about before there's an entropy
of B there's an entropy of the joint
density operator a B and we can combine
them in various ways and one way you can
combine them is a quantity called the
conditional entropy of a given B where
you take the joint entropy of a and B
and you subtract off the entropy of B so
that in this Venn diagram picture
corresponds to the left-hand
Pacman right you're probably more
familiar with a mutual information which
is the overlap but the conditional
entropy is interesting and in classical
information theory it really is the
average entropy of the conditional
distributions it's the uncertainty about
a when you know B in quantum mechanics
something
range happens that if you just think
about a bell pair for example the joint
entropy of that bell pair is zero
because it's a pure state whereas if you
look at the reduced density operator
it's maximally mixed it's entropy is one
and so the conditional entropy is
negative and so you would think well
this interpretation of conditional
entropy as an oven as an uncertainty
about about a when I know B is just
nonsensical and this fact that the
conditional entropy could be negative
was observed back in the 1950s and
mathematical Pfister said well that
means conditional entropy in quantum
mechanics doesn't mean anything it
doesn't have any good interpretation
because it seems like would require you
to be more than certain which is just a
nonsensical statement well it actually
does mean something and what it means
was written about in what is far and
away my favorite well my popular science
news article with my favorite title of
all time scientist knows less than
nothing
and so it was these three guys who are
deskey Oppenheim in winter who who
figured out what what negative
conditional entropy means and just
conditional entropy in general and the
answer is that the conditional entropy
of a given B is the number of Belk pairs
required to teleport a to be in some
sense when B is already present at the
destination and that makes sense even
when the conditional entropy is negative
and in that case the cost in bell pairs
is zero and the process actually
generates Bell pairs that they could use
in a future around of the protocol and
that's the process of entanglement
distillation and so just the labor the
point because we should get to our
discussion but this quantity is really a
conditional entropy in disguise and so
once you realize that you can just use
this this protocol of Chordettes key
Oppenheim and winter and in sequence
adding up a bunch of conditional entropy
terms and incrementally sending the
state from Alice to Bob and you get the
formula that we're talking about and now
we'll get to the discussion well I had
quote many I asked to ask the questions
so so what I just told you about
establishes some some very interesting
link between the space of curves and the
bulk and the ways that you can compress
quantum mechanical information and what
we would really what we're really in
arrested in is whether space can emerge
from entanglement itself and I'd say
that this result is some kind of hint
that this should be possible a hint that
something more general and more powerful
should be true and Dubai WA well I don't
know how to explain that the the slide
just because it sets up the discussion
but I don't want to anger okay so I'll
mention this so what I just told you
about um we can we can see it as
evidence that something more general
more powerful should be true and this
goes back to an observation of the
Dallas back in 2007 that if you have a
conformal field theory there's an
efficient way to approximately represent
the ground state of that theory this
conformally yeah the scale-invariant
state and the way you do it is you
represent that state as the contraction
of a bunch of small tensors and the
tensors are organized in this
scale-invariant fashion that i've drawn
on the right so each little dot core is
a tensor so it's some collection
multi-dimensional matrix of of numbers
if there are three lengths it's a three
dimensional matrix if there are four
edges coming out of a vertex it's a four
dimensional matrix and you just contract
them all together and that gives you a
representation of the the set of
amplitudes in some basis for the ground
state bryan Swingle who's in the room
noticed at some point that the this
network looked a lot like hyperbolic and
like some discretized version of
hyperbolic space that if you wanted to
count the didn't determine the distance
from A to B you could count the minimal
number of Link's you had to cut to go
from A to B through the graph and that
looked a lot like the fish counting
metric and on the previous slide so and
moreover when these networks are
constructed they form some way of
compressing the boundary state into what
looks kind of like the bulk and that's
sort of just a pictorial connection
between these these tensor networks this
particular one is called the multi scale
entanglement renormalization on sots and
hyperbolic space and one of the things
that we'd like to do in this business
is put you know put legs onto this
tensor network picture really show that
the tensor network can be constructed
and that the say the length of this
curve would be the sum of the entropies
of the links in the in via and in the
network so what we need from quantum
information theory one of the things we
need is to find a way to actually
perform this compression in a canonical
way and there's a question yeah is that
possible
yeah and I'm well that's a question we
could we can discuss it I'm not going to
try to tell you about it and then there
are other questions that I just thought
I'd try to lay out there for discussion
and we can go through them in turn but
I'll just tell you you know some of the
things that I thought were worth worth
trying to think about so what kinds of
conditions on this boundary state are
necessary for some cut for a consistent
geometry to emerge in this sort of
picture if this picture is right right
if we can actually identify the tensor
network at least in some coarse-grained
way with the geometry what does that
teach us right yeah does it answer any
questions for the physicists would
actually like answer it or is that just
sort of a you know mathematical
curiosity does this picture answer or
what types of things are missing from
this picture there's a the reasons to
think that it's it's hard to use it to
look at the geometry at sufficiently
fine grained scales and it's also
totally static right we're just talking
about space we don't know anything about
the dynamics of these tensor networks
and that sort of brings us into another
question this is all about space and if
entanglement is supposed to stitch space
together
what stitches time together is there
some notion of entanglement in time or
what are the appropriate information
theoretic quantities to discuss in that
context I think actually some the
computer computer scientists here may
have things to say about that I'll just
toss that the word history state you
know possibly being relevant and then
maybe we'll leave this for for Steve
Schenker and others the last line so
those are questions that I'm hoping
people in the audience will have
something to say about and maybe we
should just take them in turn so
we have time for at least a couple of
questions oh you know that was my idea
yeah I'm not gonna say anything yeah
this is just you know this is business
is that the audience participation
section you can actually address any of
the questions or anything else or ask me
a question but the idea is that now
we're just supposed to set up a
discussion so yeah if you can answer any
of these questions that's great yeah but
you can also just ask further questions
questions beget questions